Ils ét
l'assaut du Capitole.
- Take it back! Let's go!s s s s
extrémistes comme les Proud Boys
et les Oath Keepers. Certains
vêtus d'équipement militaire,
auraient pu faire encore plussss
arrivés là?
(chaos)
Le 14 décembre 2020, le collège
électoral représentant
les 50 États, a officialisé le
résultat de l'élection tenue un
le président désigné.
Selon le comité, Donald Trump
savait qu'il avait perdu,
mais tentait de s'accrocher
au pouvoir. Certains de
comment faire.
"Durant l'une des rencontres
les plus folles de
Powell, Michael Flynn
et d'autres se sont rendus
dans le bureau ovale. Ils ont
accompagné le président dans
les salles adjacentes et dans
entre autres de saisir des
machines à compter les votes.
L'avocat de la Maison-Blanche,
présent à cette réunion
considérait qu'il s'agissait
d'une idée terrible. Elle a
finalement été écaususususususu,
dans un tweet, Donald Trump
invite ses ptitisans
à Washington le 6 janvier.
"Soyez là, ce sera fou",
écrit-ilatatatatatatatatatatata.
Cet homme, qui est entré
dit l'avoir fait sur ordre
du président.
"Ça aurait pu être le début
d'une nouvelle guerre civile",
croit l'ancien porte-parole
des Oath Keepers.
d'extrême-droite communiquaient
avec des proches de Monsieur
Trump avant le 6 janvier.
Dont Roger Stone et Michael
Flynn, photos et messages textes
"Quand Monsieur Trump nous a
demandé de battre onononononono.
Alors pourquoi le président
n'a-t-il pasitit à ses partisans
de quitter le Capitole plus tôt?
L'assaut a duré 187 minutes.
Que fa d d d d d d d d d d d d ?
Le comité tentera de répondre
c cette question dans une
prochaine audience la semaine
prochaine.
Radio-Canada, Washingto